what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I'm having
classes for my friend Jess yes
um she would you say you're like half
red pill I say I'm half red pill yeah so
I'm giving her some lessons just in life
make sure you pay attention class and my
producer blessing he's camera shy but he
he's been telling me right
you've been doing good yeah yeah he he's
um he said he's the man of his house now
oh is he now good for him anyway so
today's lesson is why dating is ruined
in 2022 dang okay so ruin ruin would
ever could come back no the marriage
rates have plummeted oh Lord plummeted
they're lower than ever in human history
and human history well that's that's a
bold statement maybe you know in the
past like 1000 years
human history yeah I don't I mean I'd
imagine like in the Stone Age it was
probably lower I don't know but look
okay okay look at that that's that's
that's not the point so this all started
in the 1950s
with
um
birth control
actually that might have happened in the
60s 1960s birth control
now what happened with the development
of birth control this led to okay
hose
before the 1960s 50s roughly you know I
don't this is just a rough you know
it women couldn't really be hoes at the
same rate like
because if if you slept with dude
he might he might get you pregnant right
so back then you had to prioritize a man
that was a
provider
um loyal
all around just the good guys the the
so-called nice guys okay that that was
what you had to prioritize because if
you didn't you would be a
because no nice guy
equals baby mama
so back then baby mama was actually you
should be ashamed if you're a baby mama
that was like the worst thing you could
do if you slept with more than like two
people you oh
[ __ ] oh
blessing how
how does a girl sound with the two as a
body count nowadays
the men pray for two because before the
60s women couldn't be hoes at the same
rate so back then the fathers were
involved
the
brothers and they would vet the guy they
would say is this guy good enough to
screw my daughter
yeah right and so they make sure he's a
provider loyal good guy the problem is
women may be attracted to a good guy but
we're not aroused by the good guys okay
so when we as women when
the hoes got the opportunity to be the
hose
they started banging they called them
all right Chads
Tyrone
[Laughter]
now what now who is Chad and Tyrone
he's the guy your girl thinks about even
when you're married to her
I'm sorry fellas Tyrone shout out Chad
shout out Tyrone shout out you know who
you are yeah Tyrone six foot
six figures
six inches
these are the tall men these are the men
that all the women want now sometimes
when girls are in their younger years
they might even you know Overlook the
six figures if he's six foot six inches
muscle you know good good looking guy
now is this the same type of husband
that they were looking for before Jess
no not not the provider so what did this
lead to
let me actually let me put a red just
what did Chad and Tyrone lead to
baby mamas
baby mamas she tell you about her toxic
baby daddy
you've heard the girls on the show say
that
Chad Tyrone
that's who they are
anyways so on top of that what happened
next so that was the beginning basically
birth control gave women the ability to
sleep around okay that that step that's
phase one
of you know
dating going to [ __ ] phase two no
fault
divorce
so not only could the women screw the
Chads and tyrones the wives could could
screw the Chads and tyrones now these
are the girls that are fours five six
and seven they're sleeping with Chad's
Howard don't matter if they're married
or not they don't care
they don't they don't they don't can't
trust these hoes
ain't loyal
is the government granted women the
ability
to leave
and leave we did
when the rate of women on birth control
increased marriage decreased divorce
increase and then before it was a big
deal to get a divorce
how women like like it was actually
pretty hard not women can leave whenever
they want
yeah they can just and go screw the
Chads and tyrones the next thing that
happened before
the 1960s for birth control the other
issue was if a woman left her husband or
made poor decisions she would be
homeless if she screwed everyone in the
town
nobody would want to date her after
now we have the incoming
simps
people that marry baby mom she's got two
kids from two different dads who cares
you're here
so you all started bailing them out and
if the Sims didn't bail them out right
if the bail out the baby mamas the next
thing would be
the government
um
so in the 1960s that is when you see
in the UK it's free housing for single
mothers oh wow and yep yep in the U.S
it's just a bunch of programs and it
depends on the state right but I
but in a lot of States you know
free [ __ ] it's like you get a house
you get money from the government if you
pay people to be single mothers more
people will
now what happened next social media
the ultimate GE ego inflator okay women
all right this is what social media did
here here's a girl this is let's let's
take let's say this is what should we
name her Jess Susie Susie okay
now Susie what would we rate Susie one
to ten I should probably go four maybe
five
she's not a whale she's a stick
oh I can't see Susie sorry Susie okay
she's like on the higher end no I mean
I'm just saying she's not fat we could
keep her four you want to be a four say
six six okay Susie is a six no six is
cute right
however Susie with the development of
birth control has been screwing
nines tens this is Chad
Tyrone Etc and then what she does is she
goes on Instagram like the Instagram
logo
post a picture
and gets likes hearts
from athletes
entertainers
who else actors let's put in actors no
these men would never
how many rappers are gonna are gonna
wife Susie
none none none but she thinks that she's
on the athletes the entertainers the
actors you know maybe maybe it's not
them but the equivalent right she thinks
that she's on their level she's not
she's just been screwing up and so then
then what Susie does
screwing up
is she she now
has slept with all these guys that don't
want her she's got low self-esteem right
no sorry let me cut that she's got high
self-esteem because she thinks she's
this hot but the guy that's really gonna
this is Joe over here this is Joe
now Joe
let's say he's a six point oh shoot
let's say Joe is a 6.5 so he's slightly
better looking he would take so Susie
seriously but she's been ran through by
these guys and now his wife
it's got this high ass body count she
slept with all these guys she really
wants these guys and she says fine I'll
marry Joe
time's running out dang
and it basically inflated and now
Susie's just a metaphor for average
women mm-hmm
that think they're deserving of athletes
entertainers when really
they were deserving of Joe but Joe's
like this is my wife she's been ran
through by all the entertainers the
athletes
whoever
and now that's why dating's ruined
because what happens is then Joe and
Susie get married
and she's like I'm not really happy in
this so she's cheating
with these guys all right she's like
holla at me and then eventually
she leaves breaks up the marriage
because women leave 70 to 80 percent of
the time
dang that's high
yes 90 of your college educated so I
mean you got a college degree 90 chance
we leave I promise baby we'll be good
we'll be good I promise baby
and that's why dating is ruined in 2022
because
I'm gonna just do a recap because first
birth control allowed hoes to be hoes
then
the provider the then the hose don't
pick the providers they pick the Chads
then no fault divorce allowed the host
to leave
then the government funded them leaving
and then social media made girls that
are sixes think their nines and tens and
deserve nines and tens and think they're
too good for the guy that's on their
level and then they marry the guy that's
on their level and then they're thinking
about these guys and they're like damn I
wish I could have had those guys and so
what they do
is they break up their home because they
think they can do better and they can't
but then what happens at the end of the
day there's no consequence because of
you simps who bail them out
class dismissed